now that Messi has the World Cup you
can't even compare Ronaldo to Messi it's
yeah I I really don't think you can you
can't compare them now even before I
wasn't even putting them in there well
listen before I did because I wasn't a
fan of soccer then I started watching
the videos here okay and I'm looking at
the videos the level of skill there's no
comparison messy is
leagues above what is the term I don't
know if you say leagues
Ronaldo's renault's a better physical
specimen in his prime
[Music]
more powerful shot that's political
though what's going on it's not
political let's not get into the
benching let's talk about earlier in the
in the peaks of their career right I
think what we're seeing right now this
decline of Ronaldo okay we were talking
about this a little bit earlier as well
is that because he relied more on his
physical ability now that his physical
ability has declined his Effectiveness
on the field on the pitch if you will
has also declined yeah right now that he
can't run as fast now he isn't as
powerful now that he can't be as
physically imposing and dominant his
ability to affect the game has lessened
at a faster rate than Messi who's always
a much more skilled player yeah so if
you had to compare them to NBA players
you said uh Messi to you with Steph
Curry Steph Curry so who is Cristiano
Ronald and let me say why and let me see
why I say that he's Steph Curry in terms
of like Steph Curry gets his buckets he
has immense skill don't get me wrong he
has immense natural gifts but he gets
his buckets by outsmarting his opponents
using every little move to move that
person a fraction of an inch and when
they're at fraction there's take
advantage of that opportunity that he
created when I'm watching these
highlights of Messi I'm like this guy is
solving three problems ahead every
single time it's amazing to watch him
work he's doing one geek that he knows
is going to move this Defender but he
can't kick the ball too far because he
has another Defender that he has to move
around and then a third one that he's
preparing for and I'm looking at this
guy and I'm like holy [ __ ] not only is
he incredibly impressive in terms of
problem solving but also selfless yes
like he'll solve three problems and then
he maybe could take a shot at goal but
he'll make the more high percentage play
pass it off and then that personal score
like Raymond his decision making is
insane yo and then Mark was like yeah he
I mean yeah you're like you basically
call him autistic yeah yeah but in like
the most beautiful way the guy's a
[ __ ] genius he's applied the autism
to football Moroccan football and he
succeeded and I watched Ronaldo play and
I see a guy with immense physical gifts
but not the same problem solving ability
and it's probably because he hasn't had
to solve the problems it's like a guy
like I mean LeBron is not the right
comparison because that's um I compare
them to Simply in terms of decision
making but the thing about LeBron is
that LeBron is so one so selfless use
your Kobe comparison was really good but
I think Kobe's problem solving was maybe
more Elite I think like James Harding
the game came so easy to him he was able
to bully get some space create history
second the physical ability star to
leave it's like you know who it might be
it might be like Giannis antetokounmpo
once Giannis antetokounmpo starts to
slow down but we don't know that yet we
don't know it yet yeah but once his
physical ability no longer can affect
the game yeah it's going to be hard for
him to dominate piece he can't fall back
on these Elite skills like Messi Messi
you could watch him right now he's not
going to beat somebody in foot race like
we were watching the final if it's
one-on-one just Racing for the ball he's
gonna lose every single time now before
that [ __ ] would but now he
wouldn't but he's still effective
because if he gets the ball within space
he can he was involved with every
scoring play yep so so that's that like
Elite IQ and I had coaches like this we
would play with our coaches I'd be like
15 16 and we're all like running super
crazy energy and we play with the coach
who's like 50. but mentally his decision
making was so good and his change of
speed was so good he could hang with us
and he'd make fun of us like oh you let
an old man beat you but like if it's a
foot race we'll beat him but just his
ability to still play even at an old old
age just due to his like agility and
mental game was like unmatched so here's
first thing so here's something that's
interesting if we're saying uh Messi's
past Ronaldo the Gap is only going to
grow because from what I'm hearing
Ronaldo very much relies on the physical
and Messi he can keep aging they're
about the same age right Messi's gonna
keep being good for a few more he was
amazing in this world cup yep second
most goals and probably had more
assistant mbappe overall so like
contributed to more points so he's just
gonna keep he's going to keep playing at
a high level theoretically and Ronaldo's
kind of going to start uh regressing a
lot more I think that was a little I
think when I was a little older he's a
couple years older okay but they're
closer no 38 I think so and then Messi's
let 35 yeah and this is where I compare
I was comparing Messi's decision making
to LeBron's and I compared Ronaldo to
Kobe based on what I've heard which is
Kobe wants it all on him at all times
for better and For Worse issued his mind
and you respect that but I think that's
what it seems like Ronaldo is like if
y'all didn't use me enough if we and we
won the World Cup I don't give a [ __ ]
I'm walking off I'm pissed at the coach
you didn't play me enough I don't know
if Messi's like that and that's how I
also think LeBron is it's like yo
whoever gets a shot if we win is good
regardless we all just witnessed the
greatest World Cup finals in history
greatest World Cup in history maybe the
greatest World Cup so I have to ask you
guys the question this is what everybody
on the internet wants to know I watched
One World Cup
is it
now that we've watched the greatest
World Cup and the greatest World Cup
Final in history
it's worth the people that died building
the stadiums right like we can have no
no I'm asking to say that the internet
is asking the question no the internet
is asking no one said let me ask you
this okay after watching the game you
feel a little bit more at least so that
was a lot of people from Morocco there
bro that's not true Pakistan it was
worth it
hey if you asked me actually it was
worth it now
do you think if there are any fans of
soccer
do you think that there are any fans
there with these massive messy fans and
they're like if I am going to give my
life building these stadiums at least
let Messi win his first World Cup do you
think that there's a little bit maybe
that's how they want how he won human
sacrifice
they offered themselves up to God
come on L what what you got to say was
it Castle was it Catholics that died
Catholics that died I don't know who
died I'm just saying what do you you
awfully quiet [ __ ]
I'm not on board with this one I'm bored
with what also people shouldn't have to
die to play kickball bro come on bro you
shouldn't what if it was to build the
Super Bowl what was it now that's a game
[Laughter]
who died I didn't say anybody died I
also didn't say this how I feel the
internet was asking this question who
allegedly died was it pakistanis I don't
know the people that were building the
stadium allegedly were they black
I think they were Brown
oh she said why y'all putting me in I'm
just saying I'm just saying
hypothetically no yeah it was a bunch of
people from Finland there was a lot a
lot I would care about your people hey
you're right who cares about it if it
was Sweden all right that's the only
place I'll be like all right it's fine
see what I'm saying so just imagine it
was sweets imagine it was 500 Suites
died building them stadiums yeah so
messy could finally get it just Ikea
cranking first yeah I know I would
imagine I've done an uncomfortable
station what happened
it's all plastic it came in flat build
your own suit that would be horrible all
I'm saying is a lot of people are trying
to have that conversation and I thought
I would pose that question to you guys
was it so good that it makes you feel a
little bit better about that we all feel
horrible that these people died but you
feel a little bit better it was so good
you're gonna forget that people died
maybe that's the better way conveniently
block that out of your memory is that
and when you talk about this world cup
remember when this started and I'm not
picking on you this is the mentality of
everybody but you were like whole thing
feels tainted man the whole thing feels
gross and then every match was good to
the point that we were like this is the
best I mean you actually kept winning I
was like I mean
I don't I don't think they should ever
do a World Cup outside of Qatar
I think I think so far so far
good idea
Qatar is to go to World Cups if this is
the greatest World Cup ever right if
it's the greatest World Cup ever let me
tell you this we didn't miss alcohol did
we shout out to Islam we weren't there
bro
mad pressure when they go to the stands
and a girl is wearing like the jersey of
where she's from because that's how I
judge all the women from your country
yes it's a fine girl we're like yeah we
need to go girl yeah
old lady and I was like oh skip it I
don't know I think we said this before
you got to subsidize it you have to send
your best send your best bro put them on
a plane I don't care commercial plump up
your lips and get the stand yeah dude
bribe the camera guy everyone's like
bribe the Reps [ __ ] that bro bribe the
camera guy say hey tourism yeah people
gonna go to Croatia after what they're
million percent we didn't send out our
best we didn't have that it was no there
weren't a lot of American girls that we
were going to that's a great Point yeah
they're already in that's why we lost
that didn't help you know I mean it's
one hour flight yeah yeah yeah no it
didn't help also the most beautiful
American women typically you know a lot
of them are not necessarily from America
that's the other thing oh interesting
they come over they came over they came
back from Columbia
yeah
Colombia they mixed in a little they're
coming from the islands they mix in a
little so when it comes to supporting
team they're not supporting America you
know it's wild I want to talk mad [ __ ]
about you but all of our moms aren't
from America that's my point
where was your mom born in America or
Puerto Rico uh America light New York
she was born in New York oh wow she was
like the last of 11 so that's what yeah
exactly already they came up she's one
of them yeah 11. the youngest of 11.
yeah damn
ah lee bruh have you met Gramps yeah you
met Gramps yeah a cool dude I mean
obviously
yeah obvious literally yes right mad
uncles
same moms uh two were not oh two or not
oh but nine with one and then two more
yeah my dad won a nine my dad my grandpa
was born in the 1800s
[Laughter]
okay let's just get back here because we
don't want to take all episodes to
discuss this but we really can because
it is the world's game yes and we're
having this conversation for the world
the question is now that Ronaldo has not
won a World Cup
is there any player that hasn't won a
World Cup that we still talk about
we're talking about Ronaldo now so that
it's the odd the odd thing is happening
hey shut up [ __ ]
a good ass point oh quit
equipment has points making me look like
I don't know what the [ __ ] I'm talking
about [ __ ] that's my bad damn it
[ __ ] took the wind out myself
no I'm saying like historical figures
like Payless probably won a World Cup
right they all every goat won a World
Cup Pele Maradona and then now Messi
Messi Johan Cruyff oh Croix oh how could
we forget the first Johann the first
Ronaldo yeah yeah Ronaldo won one two
100 Lewandowski Robert Lewandowski he
never won nobody son these are truly
names I've never heard in my life and
I've been watching soccer for like six
days now yeah I know okay that's my
point exactly with all due respect with
all durers I can be respectful no no
with all due respect David Beckham oh
[ __ ] don't even know he plays
soccer you're just hot dude you're just
[ __ ] don't even know he played
son you're a hot dude married a spice
girl that's all I know about thank you
thank you thank you
that's what he's known for he was nice
but no World Cup forgotten it's
disappeared so he's got to take these
things off
the only reason I'm all United what is
that that's on the dollar bro
I just needed some Latin right there
I want to do a Harry Potter spell I
forgot how to do a Vida Kadabra yeah
beat it from anyone from anyone yeah
from anyone yeah exactly bro come on
conversations there can only be
oh God damn wow bruh holy [ __ ] hit it
dude that's crazy